yeah you would please welcome to this
video Baloo crows 712 43 you from Russia
that its version idea I have not yet
played a game against them let's say new
opponent let's see em the system other
principled approach against Oakland the
other one is of course the Roxy point
which I only know what this and recently
I had a game with h4 am where I got
completely murdered but escaped by a
miracle now let's see what happens here
yeah fresh mug of coffee might help so I
only know that this is this some kind of
theory but not more I mean here black at
least have something that looks a bit
scary it is i think ok so as for i
probably have to take takes with the
bishops of rook c8 i am probably correct
to go on the app open file
yeah I feel somewhat quick with age for
me this is really the kind of opening
that I am feel I could only play with
very good knowledge otherwise i would
just always be too nervous about why the
taking possibilities i mean even with
knowing stuff i probably hit thanks very
nervous okay so I wonder why is taking
so long isn't h4 obvious him I just got
the washing machine running in the
background yeah I think just h4 looks
dangerous maybe I'm relatively okay with
just playing age 5 h 5 g 4 h eight might
hold is taking a very long time oh wow
so as Bishop f5 i mean if i take bishop
f7 that's probably what he wants to do
this is just just good right threatening
1 c 2
yeah so we landed upon and turn ad for
remains bit of a weakness so let's put
this on deform yes III doesn't help him
all that much so no need to play before
or something like that he still plays it
okay but nothing I can take and put the
roof on a 40 wait he's got to be one
down okay so i put the room on c5 that's
also ok i should have maybe played h5
first to let 14 / sorry he wants to play
any form now that i can just take
should pre move that there's nothing
particularly scary yeah so he am I will
go FYI guess or enter with the King
entering you the King actually looks
better for King at four
okay so II for is no good I would like
f1 king at five but f-for he plays king
is for I'm not sure if I'm winning there
so I to improve the position first
five
I can get behind the bushes behind the
porn though check and do this Andrew
Kade having two passes and one being
supported with the look from behind
should be enough
hmm
I don't see a clean one at the moment
that's a bit puzzling I should just go
there and now a too should be lovely
just trade the two pawns I think this is
a very favorable configuration on the
King side I think it should win but
that's only technically well play it's
really not okay white resins didn't play
that well technically maybe not totally
sure them yeah we have we have this
position which is theoretically
certainly well explored but not what I
know sending the message with like seven
question marks I will know why so
anything that i missed oh I mean
probably I didn't didn't play the
technical part or that well but I mean
I'm keeping a substantial advantage here
for sure so I'm not Ken Patera no this
is this the engine gives look-see eight
which which I didn't lie because of the
is Emily the pawns are just too far
yeah this is what I did it's enormously
favorable for black that sounds of
course I have to look this up the serum
ok guys thanks for watching